hey guys it is the second of every today
my name is Jeff middle and you're tuned
into games fight me just cause 3
screenshots of leaked onto the internet
today thanks to yoga damages show a lot
of what you'd expect that is guns
explosions and Rico Rodriguez standing
atop of flying fighter jet other things
he's shown standing on top of any images
we've seen so far include an airborne
car a school bus and the gas canister
when he isn't on top of vehicles other
choice modes of transport around the
picturesque fictional archipelago
appeared to include parachutes wingsuit
and grappling onto an exploding attack
helicopter as you do Just Cause 3 is due
out sometime this year Konerko Jima has
said he'd like to see a remake of his
1998 action game Metal Gear Solid kajima
was recently asked at the taipei game
sure whether he'd like to see earlier
Metal Gear games brought to the ps4
while he was enthusiastic about the idea
he said he's too busy to work on any
projects himself as he's currently
working on the phantom pain and silent
hills kajima said that nonetheless he'd
like to play an urban world version of
Shadow Moses the location from the
original game Metal Gear Solid has
previously been remade once before for
the nintendo gamecube in 2004 with the
twin snakes and finally Sony Online
Entertainment is no longer owned by Sony
and is now operating as an independent
company the development studio who are
responsible for mmos like EverQuest next
planetside 2 h1z1 and DC Universe Online
has officially flown the nest after
being bought out by Columbus Nova and
investment management firm the studio
which is rebranding as daybreak game
company has expressed their excitement
about the move to multi-platform game
development president of the company
John Smedley tweeted can't wait to make
Xbox one games soe was founded in
nineteen
only five with the name sony interactive
studios america they were originally
tasked to develop playstation only games
but have taken to focusing on free to
play pc games of late let me know down
in the comments what you think of this
one and whether you reckon it's going to
be a blow to sony you can head to games
flat for a glimpse of pros playing
street fighter 5 and watch today's
episode and suggest to weigh in on
whether you think we should start
pre-ordering games those are all the
things that i wanted to tell you about
today be sure to leave me your thoughts
and i'll catch you same time tomorrow